okay sir why don't we stop after being
immersed into the beauty of fennel slaw
pronounced equation and Snell's law we
are going to continue with kind of
putting together a new ray tracing
problem and we know all about hourglass
interactions and things like that but we
for instance don't know what the
representation of the array of lines
could be so let's go with this so array
is basically starting somewhere and it
is going somewhere it's basically it
this is what I have written here
mathematically so this is a parametric
equation we'll talk about this in a
second so always the origin this is
where we start from D is a direction
vector this is where the weight is this
is where the Ray is going and T is the
distance that it had gone it's basically
it's so if T is a large number then the
Ray had traveled a lot and if T is 1 and
this now we are always going to talk
about vectors of unit length if we are
talking about direction vector and most
vectors are normed in good illumination
anyway but I would like to state this
because now this T is meaningful if d is
of unit length and T is a scalar it so
number 8,000 additional studies travel
and this notation is a bit weird for
many people because this R depends on T
and if you come from the regular math
courses most of what you encounter is
implicit equations so this could be an
equation of the surface f of x and y
equals 0 for instance this is an example
this would be the implicit equation of
the sphere and this is an equation so
basically you can say that whatever X&Y
that satisfy this equation is going to
be or the point of this sphere and this
is going to be this collection of points
that gives you a sphere and parametric
equations don't look like that
so with these parametric equations you
can see that the x-coordinate i can dig
out from a function that depends on t
the y-coordinate i can dig out from the
different perhaps a different function
but it also depends on T and I can write
up this whole thing as a vector form so
I'm not talking about XY but probably
vectors so let's see an example the
equation of array is such an example
that you have seen above but we're going
to play a bit more with this and the
first special is why are we doing this
why parametric equations installed
instead of implicit functions well you
will see soon enough when we encounter a
problem and this is going to be easy to
solve with parametric equations so this
is a secret and now let's try to compute
the intersection of the Ray and the
sphere so I cast array and I would like
to know which is the first object that I
hit in the scene and if I have a scene
of spheres then this is the kind of
calculation that I need to do so the
expectations are the following I have a
sphere and the Ray and it is possible
that the Ray is the sphere in two
different words
well what as impossible if two hit
points are possible then one hit point
is also possible this is essentially the
tangent of the sphere it is just hitting
at the very side well this is the very
sight of this still exists and obviously
it is possible that the Ray does not hit
the sphere level so we have again listed
our expectations before doing any kind
of the calculation and you will see that
this will make things much more
beautiful so the solution for this whole
problem should be some kind of
mathematical something that can give me
two solutions one solution or maybe no
solutions if I get if I do the
intersection routine and I get whatever
else then this should be incorrect so
this is what I expect to see there's
possibility of to one or zero solutions
well this is the equation of a sphere
he is the peas are going to be the point
in the surface of the sphere and the sea
is the center of the student or at least
of the radius this is the equation of
the Ray we have to mix these two
together in some way in order to get an
intersection what I'm going to do is I'm
going to substitute this R of T in the
play in the place of P so what it will
give me is a plus TD minus C times o
plus TD minus C equals R squared
so this is a big multiplication between
the two parentheses and if I do this
actual multiplication then I will see
that there's going to be a term which
which gives me the TD x TD so there's
going to be something like T squared d
squared here and there's going to be
another term where the old minus C is
multiplied with the TD on the other side
and this happens twice because both
sides and the rest is going to be a
scalar term because o minus C I'm going
to multiply with Oh minus C so this is
going to be a scalar I don't see T in
there and this is a very quite
interesting because if we smell this
equation what does this equation smell
like raise your hand if you if you have
some idea what this smells yes that's
that's going to be correct yes it's a
polynomial equation more difficult agree
to it exactly exactly so this is but I
have to smell it first so yes indeed
that's a quadratic equation so I have T
squared T and the scalar term equals
zero what are the coefficients were
simple and T is going to be T squared
what about to be I mean not a t body a
we apologise the B is going to be the to
do minus C because this is what I
multiply T with and the scalar term is
going to be all the rest
okay so this should be very simple to
solve I have as a solution that possible
t1 and t2 that satisfies this equation
and now the question is is it possible
that this equation has two solutions so
I'll help you out I missed some courses
at kindergarten so I don't know anything
about this is it possible to get two
solutions for this I can't hear anything
okay excellent excellent at this this is
the interesting part during a during a
lecture because the teacher asks
something and no one answers and this
can mean two things
one thing is that no one knows the
answer and the second is that yeah
anyone knows the answer and it's so
trivial that no one wants to look like
an idiot so no one says anything I would
imagine that maybe this is the second
case so is it possible to get two
solutions for this
this is excellent ok cool when well it's
simple if this B squared minus 4ac is
larger than zero that the second term
under the square root is going to be a
number some real number and therefore
this is going to be T 1 is minus B plus
this number T 2 is a minus B minus this
number and therefore this is going to be
two different solutions maybe I
shouldn't walk so much during the course
can you hear this
Contego
well now as I could take the Morpheus
and look like a an academic okay well is
one solution possible I still can't hear
anything
yes okay cool when someone tell me the
single term is equals in here excellent
okay so if this term is zero then I'm
adding zero on that subtracting zero
this is the same thing so t1 equals t2
very simple and it is also possible that
we have no real solution if this square
root term I mean the turn under the
square is less than zero
excellent so this is quite beautiful
because because we listed our
expectations and it indeed needs to look
like something that can give me 2 1 or 0
solutions and if I do the math this is
exactly what happens so this is the
beauty of the whole thing and let's
imagine that I've solved this equation
and I got the result that t1 is 2 and T
2 is minus 2 and now what if I told you
that these T's mean distances some
solving the parametric equations in a
way that is T so it means that the first
intersection is 2 times the unit
distance therefore 2 in the front there
could be a solution which is a classical
case for a quadratic equation where I
get the second solution that is minus
something what does it mean yes between
this mr. because it's behind our eyes so
you don't really care about that
precisely precisely so it is possible
that the race starts in the middle of
the sphere and then this is indeed a
perfectly normal thing to happen that
there's one intersection in front of us
and there's one intersection to our
backs and obviously we don't care about
it too much and if you find a solution
like this we discard it indeed so you're
studying computer science and we are not
coming
because if we would be studying politics
we will be interested interested in what
happens behind our backs this is the
leader side so we can discard all this
information